foreign
[Music]
and welcome back to Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong from the Rotten Tomatoes Studio
here in Southern California I am Mark
Ellis with me as always Jack and Coley
we're back in studio and we have a lot
to celebrate because we taped this last
week yeah and it was a very big day for
me personally and my my football team
because we're selling the team yeah the
owner is getting out Jacqueline I fee
you know what we're talking about a
Christmas movie Christmas came early for
Mark Ellis I really do feel like this is
when we got the rumors that Janelle was
filing for Giselle was filing for
divorce I will not celebrate with you
until it was like a couple of days ago
when she actually did divorce him for
the reasons that she absolutely should
have never married him very fair and
again this is just beginning the process
it's gonna be a long process but I kind
of feel like you know you know what this
is this is uh Tim Robbins in Shawshank
and he's got the spoon yeah and he's got
the spoon own and Tim Robbins has
initiated making dents in concrete walls
and we're getting out we're getting out
but we're talking about Christmas and
happy things and we're getting to that
Time of the Season where it's not
necessarily the Christmas season yet but
you're preparing for Christmas sort of
like in Spaceballs preparing preparing
you're always preparing well one of the
best days to prepare for Christmas is
the day after Thanksgiving colloquial
known as Black Friday yes when everybody
goes shopping there's lines people are
throwing elbows and they're diving after
knees to get that toy to get that hot
item and so what better movie to talk
about than jingle all the way which is
currently 19
rotten on the Tomato Meter it picks up a
little steam with the audience score but
still rotten at 38 percent and so here
to help us disseminate why is a member
of the generation raised on jingle all
the way I imagine it is our incredible
producer himself you know him as one of
the stars of the Wanger show he's a
Creator he's an actor he does it all
Brian Perez is here hey happy to be here
are you I am happy to be here talking
this movie I love this movie and I know
it was my time it was before or after
your guys's time like you guys are a
little too old no no offense it wasn't
after we're still here talking about it
Brian I'm still talking about it but we
actually understood it for the satire
childhood really quickly like
legitimately with relish because I
I have a different take on
okay yeah I'm excited I have a third
take on this movie because I base this
movie entirely on where Arnold
Schwarzenegger was in his career this
was not a Christmas holiday movie for me
this was sort of like are we getting
near the end of one of the greatest runs
of that anybody's ever seen in the
history of Hollywood with Arnold
Schwarzenegger being a box office star
we were just getting started with this
movie how dare you say this is the end
of this run come on 96 all right well
before we get into we have two minutes
with Tim which is where he's gonna tell
us where the critics were saying at the
time of this film's release which was
1996. Schwarzenegger coming off of
eraser and it was right before he would
be in Batman and Robin and so again
interesting time in his career is
starring Sinbad as well who was one of
the all-time uh great stand-up comics as
far as how prolific he is with material
he used to host those Caribbean shows
for HBO the guy is just he's an
incredible comic I don't think he gets
the credit that he deserves in that
realm and then he had a nice run as a
movie star and he this is his third
movie that he was in with Phil Hartman
so we're going to get into all that but
before we get into any of the movie Talk
itself I'm curious both of y'all did we
ever do the Black Friday did we have a
big day where I wait till Cyber Monday
now that seems safer no I did I did do
Black Friday I also worked retail for
more years than I can remember on Black
Friday
you know okay okay I work Toys R Us but
not for was it Black Friday Toys R Us
Black Friday so I worked for I'll say it
I worked for the TJX Corporation at
different points both in stores and at
the corporate office for
God I want to say almost almost a decade
like like seven or eight years wow I
like moved up the ranks though so I was
like let me let me like make this math
like 2009 until 2000. oh seven years
okay okay yeah six seven years I worked
we handled some Black Friday issues only
handle some Black Friday issues which is
also the reason why I have my take on it
which is that this movie was trying to
satire spectacle consumerism and it
really just gave permission
consumerism this was the beginning of
the death rattle of people at least
pretending that they weren't trying to
buy themselves into a personality and
into a family
this was like the last gas of us trying
to pretend that capitalism wasn't gonna
kill us all yeah this was really the
death of not only
um a lot of facades about Christmas but
also for Santa Claus and those poor
elves up there this was the movie that
came out it's like no more wooden toys
yeah no more train sets real stuff
because you know what happened Christmas
in 96 this movie comes out in November
Christmas in 96 was the Tickle Me Elmo
Christmas yes yes so it's almost like oh
my God art is becoming life right before
our very eyes have you ever waited in
line like overnight for anything no uh
[Music]
Velvet Rope NSYNC concert tickets okay
so this is the Janet Jackson Velvet Rope
tour
um and I will admit although I love
Janet Jackson I was buying the tickets
for Usher and in sync because wow
I understand it I don't agree with it
I'm there for Janet
I'm there for Rhythm Nation I'm there
for black cat Escapade that's what I'm
there for I was there for
their 14 year old girl has different I
get it I get it I don't I never want to
be you I never want to be a 14 year old
girl trying to get in sync tickets I
know you love Van Halen but at that time
if you could have gone and hung out with
Pamela Anderson uh I still might have
taken Van Halen
um
I wasn't into I wasn't into that what
was the girl I like him more I like a
different sort is what I'll say yeah
who's my girl see Perez Rosie Perez I
was high on Cindy Crawford was my love
oh yeah either way okay either way Cindy
Crawford in her Diet Coke fabulousness
is saying Pepsi but yes yeah sorry sorry
Diet Pepsi fabulousness is saying Mark
come over today but you have to skip the
Van Halen concert yeah yeah I'm going to
I'm going to the Crawford residence
thank you so don't be mad at me because
I bought the tickets for Instinct and
Usher okay so she's got she's got a a
music concert I have a film what did you
wait in line overnight mine was video
games I stayed but it was super early
for the Nintendo 64 with Mario 64 and
with golden eye absolutely waited early
at the Toys R Us and was one of the
first ones to get it but do you hear
this like the stories around what we're
getting yeah is not the stories that we
tell I enjoyed velvet row but the story
behind me getting the tickets and like
that whole thing is like way more and
that's like I think what this movie sort
of shows and that's the game like they
make us feel like it's like the Hermes
and all of that like it's like you have
to pay through the teeth so by the time
you actually get the bag which is never
going to be as fulfilling as it was
intended to be the present as this movie
shows us is never is going to be as
fulfilling as it's meant to be
you know what it is it's like a great
Championship season where yeah we we won
the trophy or maybe we didn't win maybe
we lost in the final finals but it's
about the journey you took with that
team when I waited in line for Star Wars
phantom menace tickets that was really
my first Comic-Con that was my first
Star Wars celebration because you're
just there with a bunch of other Star
Wars nerds and so it's more about the
camaraderie getting the thing that it is
the thing itself but here we have a
rivalry Between Two Dads who are just
looking to get some respite and get
their family's approval by getting a
turbo Man doll the last Turbo Man doll
that is going to be available in this
town for quite some time and we want the
actual turbo man not a gift certificate
all right so here is what we're gonna do
first Jaclyn's gonna give us a brief
synopsis of jingle all the way and they
fun that it entailed at your ready yes
so jingle all the way is Mark and our
lovely Preamble said is sort of this
1990s comedy that takes place with the
idea of a family of two trying to find
the perfect Turbo Man toy and it sort of
capitalized sell out culture it starts
Sinbad Arnold Schwarzenegger now
basically think trains planes and
Automobiles but these who are going
through the Mad adventure of getting the
very last toy because there's a pencil
for it at the very end in addition we
have lots of other folks coming along
the way including Phil Hartman and Rita
Wilson but the main thing is just these
two people who are trying to achieve
this one family thing together and
having everything including each other
prevent them from it playing Trains and
Automobiles but instead of trying to get
home for Christmas we're trying to buy a
toy man that's good toy we're trying to
buy our child's love our child's love
we're trying to buy our child's love I
want to make that very clear both of
these I should have said are dads that
are too busy not present not doing what
they need to do they are literally the
product of the 80s excess whereas and
they were chasing them cars and them DVD
players but they were not chasing
emotional intelligence and family time
yes we're gonna put some therapy on this
one because this is jingle all the way
I'm going to break you on this one Brian
this is gonna be fun I really you have
to say this was a movie that I also did
love and then when I re-watched it I was
like we are all doomed
the third act gets a little crazy yeah
so before we turn it over to two minutes
but Tim I will point out one of the
other stars of the movie happens to be
star of Star Wars episode one of the
things
that I wanted to mention that this was
back before the Nerds killed him yeah
that's right yeah that's right yeah he
was just a little kid who won the turbo
Mandel yeah now it's time for two
minutes with Tim Tim Ryan our expert
review curation manager gonna tell us
what critics were saying at the time of
jingle all the ways release getting
towards the holiday season in 1996 hit
at them
means with Tim I was reading a review
Years Ago by Andrea Granville a great
critic for the Chicago Reader where she
wrote the comedian sidbad once said that
Hollywood seeks out original talents but
then tries to make them just like
everyone else Sinbad's co-star and
Jingle All The Way Arnold Schwarzenegger
couldn't possibly be like anyone else if
he tried and it's in the movies where
he's playing someone who's ostensibly a
regular guy that throw his uniqueness
into bold relief sure there's something
almost otherworldly about an Austrian
bodybuilder who plays Conan the
Barbarian or the Terminator or a guy
named John Matrix but those characters
are totally believable within the worlds
they inhabit but what about the irony
movies set in the real world movies like
True Lies and kindergarten cop and to
some degree Total Recall have fun with
the idea of Arnold as an action hero
disguised as a working stiff but why
would any of the other characters in
these movies be fooled in Jingle All The
Way his character is a mattress salesman
named Howard Langston let me repeat
Arnold Schwarzenegger's character's name
in Jingle All The Way is Howard Langston
and he's a mattress salesman does he say
so buff by carrying a stack of
mattresses out of the warehouse every
day Arnold's Reign is the box office
king during the 1990s coincided with an
era in which each holiday season spawned
a new Toy Craze in which stores were
overrun with parents so desperate to get
their hands on a Cabbage Patch Kid or a
Furby or a tickle me elbow that they
occasionally committed acts of violence
as a side note despite its R rating
Terminator 2 toys did brisk business in
1991 though it wasn't the kind of hot
commodity that would extend the likes of
Howard Langston running all over town
Howard Langston
but while Jingle All The Way attempted
to satirize such crass commercialization
of Christmas critics largely felt that
its talented cast strained too hard for
laughs and the film's tone was often too
Grim to work up much holiday cheer
jingle all the way is rotten at 19 on
the Tomato Meter with 47 reviews and it
has a 38 audience score so what did the
critics have to say in a rotten review
Margaret mcgurk of the Cincinnati
Enquirer wrote the overall effect is
disquieting too simplistic for an adult
comedy and too angry for a children's
movie however in a fresh review Andy
Saylor of USA Today wrote here's irony
of all people playing a bedraggled
suburbanite and is perversely amusing
casting boosted crass sometimes nasty
and finally funny celebration of holiday
Mass merchandising and greed the Rotten
Tomatoes critics consensus reads Arnold
Schwarzenegger tries his best but Jingle
All The Way suffers from an uneven tone
shifting wildly from a would-be satire
on materialism to an antic slapstick
yuck Fest so that's Jingle All The Way
Tata Turtle Man
yeah that was turbo man that is a that
is uh yeah that was a great sign off Tim
I will give you kudos for that one I'm
glad that Tim pointed out the Cabbage
Patch Kids Grace because that's what
this movie was sort of directly based on
and then you had other toy crazes since
then so we'll talk about the movie but
then closing things out here I am
curious if anybody had like that toy
that was like that season and you needed
to have it and you got it or you didn't
get it but for right now let's go ahead
and jump into movie talk
foreign
and I guess we could just kick off with
the easiest question here is when how
old were you when you first saw the
movie it seems like you were a ute I was
a ute uh I don't know how old I was but
I had it on VHS like one of those big
box VHS boxes and I think I just saw it
I just played it over and over again and
saw it on cable all the time so I just
grew up with this movie was it the
clamshell like the Disney case yeah yeah
that was the way I saw it as well yeah I
saw it semi babysitting oh so it just
sort of like gets into you as you're
probably calling your boyfriend to come
over or you're just like a legitimate
like babysitting type thing because this
was 96 96 yeah it was like me hanging
out with like girls that were
babysitting their younger sisters and
they were watching Jingle Bells you know
what I mean like like a semi babysitting
situation and I do remember I do believe
it was clamshell or Disney Channel but
it was like that it was either Disney
Channel or clamshell but it was
definitely kids around laughing at it
loved it at that time as like the like
tween that doesn't want to pretend like
you're into a but you're like into it
like we were into it you know this but
this is one of the very few times in the
history of this podcast that I am
talking about a movie that I'm very
familiar with now no idea when I first
saw it because I did not care about this
movie when it came out I was 15 or 16. I
was just it wasn't in my wheelhouse at
all like I got it I got what the thing
was and to be honest if I was gonna go
see this movie probably would have been
for Sinbad as much as anybody else yeah
because I was a huge Arnold
Schwarzenegger fan but he made True Lies
was a movie that when I saw the poster
for it I was like I don't know what this
guy where this guy's career is going
true lives ended up being great it's
great it was great but then he had
Junior and he had was Kindergarten Cop
before this kindergarten kindergarten's
car was before this was 89 yeah I
actually enjoy see this is what's weird
Kindergarten Cop I can enjoy is a
straight comedy okay it's funny I never
saw Arnold in the first Terminator
before I saw him the second Terminator
and so for me he was more Junior twins
Kindergarten Cop right then he was
actually
yeah like I was way more betrayed by
like Ice Cube turning into a comedy dude
than I was Arnold all of a sudden
becoming the Hollywood machine that he
had always meant to be like I always was
like this guy wants to be famous yeah
like that doesn't strike me but like Ice
Cube was like f you and now he's like
are we there yet yeah by the same guy
directed by the same guy exactly yeah uh
Brian Levant yeah yeah and so if you
look at this movie in terms of like what
you were going to see it for you
probably kept re-watching it was this
like a movie that was sort of hey I want
whatever is coming out for Christmas
this year and so this is the movie to
kind of get me into the spear because
you need a movie it's not necessarily
the movie watch on Christmas Eve with
your family or Christmas day but you
need a movie that opens up the Christmas
season for you like Mariah does for all
of us on social media now on November
1st yes this is this movie it's it's it
brings you put you in the spirit of like
it's time I know it's shopping I get it
consumerism at its worst I get it you
can't blame it on this movie like that's
just that's just the world in general
how many Amazon packages did you guys
get a day come on that's consumers you
can call me out all you want but that
was the reason why this was depressing
because I was sitting in a mound of
Amazon boxes packing them up for returns
watching this and it just depressed the
hell out of me but keep going okay but
yeah it puts you in the spirit it's the
holiday season the music's great the
comedy is great the action is fantastic
and yeah I mean I love Sinbad and uh
growing up I didn't know now that I've
grown up and seen Phil Hartman and Chris
Parnell and like all the comedy people
that are in there Martin Mull Martin
Mull yeah like I just love it Chris
Parnell so underrated at how good of a
comedian he is and like timing because
he's always the guy that comes in like
with the beat and just goes and
everybody breaks up he's perfect I
believe uh trained at North Carolina
School of the Arts I might have to look
that up but uh yeah yeah he's just yeah
very underrated a side character to the
Will Ferrell exactly she got all the
fame but but like you need that guy to
just give you the one pause and like I
said like he's like the perfect like one
line One Moment One hmm you die yeah as
is Phil Hartman as this marmy neighbor
who is just a creep but he's just he's
Phil Hartman yeah and so one of the
questions that we have on our on our
outline here is why are all the
neighborhood ladies who are single yeah
like why do they just think Phil Hartman
is the top what they all want to be with
him giving them all fellatio I won like
I get it it's a children's movie well I
know what that guy's doing the thing
okay
the guy in the neighborhood that all the
ladies love is because he's the guy in
the neighborhood that all the ladies
love I think he probably was very good
in the sack a couple times early in his
career and then word about Ted spread
around to all the different uh country
clubs and coffee shops and sampling but
but not Rita Wilson not Rita Wilson not
Rita Wilson because she's married to
Arnold Schwarzenegger's character and
their relationship is a little strange
not unless like the relationship with
Jamie Lee Curtis and Arnold
Schwarzenegger in true wise because he
has another regular job and I love Tim
talking about this his regular job in
true wives is at least the one that he
claims is computer salesman and his
family never questions like man he's
putting a lot of hours in at the gym and
then you have jingle all the way which I
understand why he's so shredded like you
ever go to mattress mattresses I help
friends move mattresses are heavy but do
you think he's moving them he's not as a
Salesman yeah he's a warehouse guy he
had to start somewhere you know what the
funniest thing in the world is is that
the like Arnold Schwarzenegger looks
like a movie star but he sounds like
Arnold Schwarzenegger and his name is
Arnold Schwarzenegger and the biggest
comedy of Hollywood was fitting this guy
into these roles that clearly were
written for guys that looked like the
two of you no offense no he's taking the
Everyman every man and then they had to
do it it boggles my mind now like don't
ever tell me you couldn't have cast the
black girl y'all made Arnold
Schwarzenegger what's his name in this I
think it's like Howard Harold Langston
Harold Langston yeah yeah look yeah yeah
that is a there's no reference to it
except for one line do you know the one
line oh I don't remember right like they
don't bring up like you're a bodybuilder
you're you're from Austria like who are
you like you're an alien here but
there's one line when he gets in trouble
for stealing
um the Phil Hartman's kids Turbo Man
right and then Phil Hartman which is an
ad-lib line he says you can't bench
press you're way out of this one
and the only reason why he says that is
like with Phil Hartman's kids because he
does have a line with him about like I
knew he had in line with him about
working out oh he did yeah yeah no that
one I didn't remember what the code was
I didn't get a line with him about
working well the the I think part of the
fun of this movie and actually what I
enjoyed re-watching it for the show is
that apparently Sinbad and Arnold
Schwarzenegger did a healthy dose of
improv in the movie Sinbad improvise
lines he really does the same thing as
stand-up I mean the guy is not known for
writing down his set list you know he
just kind of goes up and
it's very rare that you can just and and
I mean like you know you know what your
set is going to be but just really
talking off the top of your head Sinbad
is just one of the best that that has
ever come along to do it and so Arnold
Schwarzenegger by proxy I think I think
hung in there well it was sort of like
like when Jeff Daniels was acting
opposite Jim Carrey and Dumb and Dumber
it's like you have this huge comedy
Superstar can you keep up and I thought
Arnold could keep up so watching their
Dynamic back and forth I think is still
a highlight then go back to this movie
and appreciate where the movie loses me
Jacqueline is when we get into the third
act and I know it's a heightened family
comedy but it gets ridiculous and you
put an entire parade of people at risk
with this with these Antics like at some
point there needs to be some serious
jail time for these two
I got you kid
[Music]
ding down kick
[Music]
so this is what the film kind of breaks
down for me that's the spectacle like
that's where we just we live in the
spectacle and like not to be too like
explicit with it but that's the money
shot that all of this Preamble is
getting towards that's fair they want it
that's really all they want they wanted
to real Turbo Man with the jet pack the
real working jet pack and a boomerang
and everything just at a parade and
that's the part of this movie it's so
depressing to watch like I'm not kidding
you I watch this movie and I found it in
completely depressing because of where
it was and where it is now I could no
longer watch it as comedy because this
is no longer parody this is just where
people are people do stomple over each
other yes for like there's been so many
people to the point now where Black
Friday is something that we're pulling
back from because people realize how
horrible it is for everyone involved and
so when I look at this film I just see
it now as a permission structure for
this type of holiday festivity I see a
movie like this and I see the events at
play on and I say thank God for the
internet not always but the reason why
people are pulling back on Black Friday
is because you get all those Cyber
Monday sales and it's it's click and buy
yeah it's so much easier to have Turbo
Man come to your house yes than it would
be to actually go out to a store you're
not gonna find me anywhere near a store
on Black Friday yeah but I still think I
still think Cyber Monday is a problem
too because I do think it is just this
idea where we force people for no other
reason than everybody else feels they
have to so just participate in Cyber
Monday I you like this is the thing like
in our family like cooler than now and
yeah you're buying stuff come on what
day do you buy stuff statistically I buy
stuff when I'm depressed so like I have
my own deliveries but I just don't need
a Monday to do it it's every holiday
yeah it's like it's every day that you
know the I forget to take my meds two
days in a row then yes I'm going to be
like I need that aura
now you know why Jaclyn has an aura ring
there you go he's feeling bad and
they're like if we're gonna buy
something ridiculous and stupid that I
don't need that celebrities have at
least have it improve my health you know
when it lights up red Jaclyn's online
buying something I'm not saying I'm
above it or anything like I go Cruise or
whatever but nine times out of ten what
prevents me from actually buying it is I
know I'm only looking at it because it
is Cyber Monday and if it was actually
something I needed what ends up
happening is I put it in a cart save it
and then I'm still thinking about it
later I'll go back and buy it and I
don't care about the extra price because
I do know the spectacle of buying it is
why I'm doing it uh two questions I have
about this movie One do we not give
Myron his due because it seems like
Myron is in really the same boat as
Arnold Schwarzenegger I don't know why
Schwarzenegger besides the fact that
we've been lining up to see his movies
for the last 15 years up to this point
why is he sort of the hero dad in Myron
by the end I mean Myron I think might
actually have gotten arrested yeah yes
at the end of this movie well he did put
Jaime in danger like he fell
is the other aspect of how depressing
this is because the conceit is made by
Myron being the lesser of the two deaths
yes he doesn't get to win the average
mailman who's like yeah the black guy
with the job who which is I dare say a
tougher gig tougher especially around
the holidays tougher Geeks than a
mattress salesman something that's
actually part of the collective good
because he's actually like he works for
the government he's a civil servant he's
delivering all of your grandma's cards
that may or may not have five dollars
stuffed in them for Christmas Santa and
he has a great line of that one yeah so
he's literally been participating in
this whole thing and when he finally
gets his time to get something for his
kid after like literally doing like what
do we call it essential workers type
thing yeah and who still gets it the
salesman the guy that is all about his
bravado he's the one that actually gets
to win he's the one who actually gets to
do it the guy that lives in
commercialistic stuff is the one that
wins he's the hero of our tale I will
say Myron gets the short end of the
stick here but also Myron being a mail
carrier and having all those kids write
those letters to Santa Myron should have
been tipped off earlier the Turbo Man
was gonna be a Darwin high demand not
been able to do that they can't even
open the letters to Santa because it's
still a federal offense they have to
actually send it to the office of deers
there is an office of Dear Santa yeah
what is it where does it go um I know
dear God goes to Greg Kinnear that's the
problem I will tell you wow Dear Santa
is real it is a government agency that
is funded by a non-profit they actually
do read the letters and try to make
wishes from people there's a great
documentary that sort of breaks it down
called Dear Santa and it has been a
long-running program
in conjunction with the Postal Service I
am paraphrasing this and saying it
really poorly are you happy you tuned
into this show now you learned something
but like legitimately no he wouldn't
know because and that's again like
watching this again I was legitimately
like pretty depressed watching it did
you see the end Jamie Arnold's kid gives
him the Turbo Man though so he he feels
in another in another Stelling example
of white people
there you go things so that they can
feel better about the fact that they
still put him through hell for the past
past this I'm sorry but also the kids
Jake Lloyd's character was never in
question in this movie yes we always we
I would trust Anakin Skywalker of all
people to do the right thing over Arnold
Schwarzenegger in this movie because
Arnold Schwarzenegger and I understand
where this movie's coming from it's just
it's you didn't set out to make this
huge spectacle and ruin a parade and it
just happens you get so locked in
particularly men of a certain age get so
locked in on this one thing that we're
told we can't can't have and so then
that alpha male animalistic caveman
mentality comes out and that is all
you're focused on much to the detriment
of your family and your friends and your
kids so my other question is does Arnold
are Arnold Schwarzenegger and Rita
Wilson are they going to have a happy
marriage going forward because this is
an early movie to feature a post-credits
scene and it seems like maybe things are
getting redeemed for Howard at the very
very end of this movie oh why I don't
think so because she's she's cleaning up
after his messes he's been disappointing
his child for a while now it's going to
get to the wife he's going to be
disappointing her and she's finally
going to realize like no this guy is the
worst yeah like he's working on
Christmas Eve he's not buying anything
for us even though like you're not
supposed to buy someone's love but still
like just give him like something he
wasn't home to put the star on the tree
be real let's be real this is also a
classic example of the woman is probably
being the primary parent and he's being
the default parent meaning like he only
picks up the slack Arnold didn't this
version can't be left at home with the
kids for four hours he doesn't know what
to do and so no I don't think this is
going to be productive and that's the
other aspect of this is I again I just
it is there is a satire movie in here
that is a better satire than what they
did and I feel like they copped out on
the ending the real ending of jingle all
the way is Arnold sitting in a
two-bedroom apartment with uh no with
turbo man because that is literally all
he has because Jake and Rita are off
with their new stepdaddy a sad
depressing ending where the the parents
break up and he's just alive a lot of
sad depressing ending but that's a
Christmas movie it is not a Christmas
movie it is a spectacle satire that like
cheaps out on the ending because that
would have been the real like ending
that would have been it it's like if
real life were to happen yeah in a movie
yeah but it's a movie
The Very ending of the movie I'll say
documentary well no longer a satire
that's my hope it's a documentary up
until the point where the and a child
will lead them because like any any kid
it gets Turbo Man I I if any either one
can find me a story from 1996 Christmas
about a kid who got a Tickle Me Elmo and
then gave it to some other kid you let
me know because I don't think that is
where it becomes the more fantasy for me
like basically the
both ways it's trying to say this is
awful and these people need to be
checked but we're not going to give them
any life lessons to actually do that
we're just gonna say these people are
awful they need to be checked but we're
gonna actually show them in the end if
you act this way you still get your
happy ending and so I'm like it this is
what this thing feels like to me this
feels like a script that was written and
like got passed around that actually had
a different ending and then what they
shot ended up being this wild spectacle
broad comedy that sort of loses the DNA
it's very don't worry darling don't
worry darling had a really clear sort of
like thing that it was trying to say in
the screenplay that I read and what
Olivia Wilde directed was not that and
the changes that she made weakened the
argument this movie does the same thing
and just because it's a broad comedy
doesn't make it any less stupid so you
want a dark satire dark comedian no I
wanted to either one I'm trying to sell
Turbo Man dolls I don't care what it is
I just want it to know what it is that's
the problem it's like with the quote
said that Tim said it's like it is too
dark to actually be what it wants to be
which is what you you keep trying to
tell me that it is an uplifting
Christmas movie
I see y'all watching the same movie here
but I feel like you're focusing more on
the be on maybe the first active act and
a half maybe even the first two acts
yeah the third act that goes off the
rails and it gets into this dark
territory pardon me Steven Seagal from
where it can't recover from the ending
that I always expect to see when I
re-watch this movie and I'm always let
down that I don't is like I want to see
like a Christmas that is that both
families all coming together and like
sort of I want to see Myron and I want
to see Howard like I want to see them
next summer playing golf or so I want to
see them having a good time as like as
buddies
like I want to see like Howard showing
up at baseball games and football games
and being there for the regular part of
the year because that's the real lesson
of the movie is you don't need to try to
buy your kids love at Christmas if you
show up the other 364. do you think that
the post-credits scene was the in
reality the post-credit scene is this
he's hanging out with his wife and it
looks like they're okay we're doing it
and then the big news he has to tell her
is that he's opening another store
because the mattress sales are going so
well he's opening another store he's
going to be even busier because I don't
see him I I don't know that Myron has a
choice yeah as far as what his job is
and with Howard I think that he is just
going to continue to chase the the
financial train and and try to
rationalize it I'm improving my family
that way instead of actually to spend
more time with them who he clearly
doesn't really like all that much and by
the way I feel like I'm being real it's
really funny the first half of the movie
is there we go I'm not trying to pretend
that is not but it is schizophrenic yeah
it's total watching and I think that
like I'm not going to betray like the
weirdness I felt because when we get to
the end that's the problem like I
wouldn't have even been mad at the
spectacle if they would have just seen
that to its long to its actual
conclusion but instead they skirt off
the path right at the end and bring us
into Mayberry and like that
I will say it doesn't wait till the end
to get dark it gets dark in the middle
when they have the Santa scene with
James Belushi credited as James Belushi
yeah um and the elf holds a Polaroid of
like someone holding a turbo Man doll
saying we have one come follow me I mean
seriously it gets pretty dark it gets
really dark there and that's what but
true to life yeah you make a lot of
money off those things you do make a lot
of money off of those things and so
again this is not comedy anymore this is
people buying things right now and then
putting it immediately up on resale like
this is real this is the life this is
where we live and so there is very
little satire about it now and I think
it was us laughing at this back then
that makes us now like again it's just
it's a code I don't want to watch or
don't want to wear it doesn't mean that
I can't appreciate it for what it was
this is just not a movie where you're
like oh this was the first brick in the
wall that destroyed us so we'll say to
your point though the the movie itself
and I think I think Jack would agree
with this too the genius in the
filmmaking in this movie is the first
half and how kinetic yes the energy is
because that is the energy around
Christmas yes because I'm one of those
folks that do you know I always say
every year like I'm just going to get
all my Christmas gifts in September for
my family and then I'll be good and I
want to worry I'm never that guy no it's
uh what it's the middle of November and
I still have no I'm not I haven't even
thought that far ahead yet so I really
have an issue with that because I I will
still go to Target or wherever on
Christmas Eve and just look for whatever
I can grab last minute this movie
captures that feeling yes you really are
you're shopping Christmas Eve yeah
absolutely yeah yeah because usually I
go home I'm traveling and I don't want
to carry all that crap with me so I get
home I get back to base and then I'm
like all right because I'm kind of like
Howard where I see my family for 10
minutes and I'm like well I'm gonna run
out to Starbucks anybody need anything
no I like this about Mark which I think
is more interesting which is that Mark
is
how do I put this practical but polite
so he's polite that's a slime
no no no no no no he is practical but
he's he's polite in the sense of like of
course he's not going to be somebody
that shows up but he is practical First
yes he is practical First and that is
like the gods to honest truth so he will
never I think sacrifice practicality
for politeness but he is very polite so
it doesn't show often when he's just
like this is not practical anymore
you'll catch me in Target
approaching midnight on Christmas Eve
you're never going to catch me in an
airport on December 23rd trying to check
a bag okay so that is not happening yeah
okay practicality over polite now the
polite thing to do is like obviously
have the gift but it is not going to
Trump the practicality of I need to be
there eventually he will also add the
other P which is planning and ship the
gifts there ahead of him there yet maybe
next year because that is what I am my
head hurts I am planning over I'm sorry
I am um planning over practical and
polite meaning if it doesn't happen all
of those other things are not going to
happen like I cannot be polite without
planning yeah all right so what's the
save if I if if you were either you know
defending this movie against Jacqueline
whoever is like maybe I've never seen
jingle all the way I want you to sell me
on what's the scene for you that
captures that holiday spirit that you're
talking about it's the ball scene when
it's like we we have one more Turbo Man
or for whoever gets these balls these
little bouncy balls and they're just uh
Myron and Howard are yeah going nuts in
the Mall of America I think they
actually shot it there yeah they did
yeah um and they just it was just this
crazy fun scene that encapsulates what
Christmas shopping is all about nowadays
um but yeah that's just it's just a fun
good time can I just ask you Brian
what's that what is your Christmas like
now in your house how many people are
you guys buying gifts for what is the
way I'll set it up okay well now I have
a fiance so I have two Christmases now
on different coasts and you gotta really
impress that other family this is a big
Christmas for you so don't like talk
numbers but like like how many gifts are
y'all exchanging like how far are you
going in this we're supposed to do the
one gift per person thing but then that
all changed when I got there and it's
like hey Brian we got you 10 gifts
somebody always splurges right like yeah
yeah this is yeah you can't you can't
ever stick to that white elephant 25
under whatever the rule is somebody's
gonna come in we don't do that we give
this and say a Max of three okay three
gifts yeah per person per person wow but
we we send a list okay
um and this is actually a new tradition
of ours because I'm just tired of it
yeah like my partner is very much like
they're just gonna buy bad gifts I was
like or you can train them to give you
good ones I'm not gonna deal with 40
more years of like bad things family
members they're like dogs train them but
no I mean I mean I don't want to be like
that but like my whole thing is is like
to buy a good gift for somebody you need
to know them and as much as we like to
pretend that our family knows us at a
certain point when you're away from them
they know you less and so they're basing
stuff on what they thought you liked at
16 yes not basing it on anything that
you like now at 35.40. I'm that weird
kid that was always thrilled to get new
socks and I still do I mean I like to
buy your own socks I might have ordered
socks last night for myself I might have
sporged last night I don't disagree with
you on that because I do understand the
loveliness of colorful socks oh it feels
good it does feel good it does feel good
but I guess my whole thing is just like
with my parents as they we just got into
this thing of exchanging money and I
just got tired of it and so I was like
there's no fun though like a gift card
or just straight cash dude cash like
they are just like I give you 40 you
give me 40. I literally got so irritated
with it but it's what my mother liked
and so I am because of a lack of
planning and so now I'm like I'm just
doing it for you here's the five I like
send her an Amazon wishlist pick one and
now she'll like add her own things in
there because again you cannot force her
to make her own Amazon wishlist at 65
she ain't doing it
but if you send her an Amazon wishlist
and say what do you want out of this it
might happen we're trying it this year
like I'm saying this like it's
implemented this is my personal thing
um how many how many gifts for your
wife's or for your for your fiance's
family have you already bought uh none
none okay any Christmas presents it's
November these are
dumb
I've bought two two small gifts for my
partner and I know what I'm getting him
for his big gift because we're gonna do
Max three total I know what I'm getting
my best friend I know what I'm getting
you uh see now now I got this is the
other problem is you gotta you gotta
anticipate you got to be a good
defensive back you have to anticipate
who's giving you gifts but now you're
like oh hey uh your gift card is in the
mail it's the weirdest you don't need to
give me a gift because it's the same
gift I give everybody who I like
but who doesn't want I don't want them
to buy me a gift and Mark knows this
because I've given it I hate getting
gifts uh I love giving them I've given
this to you two years in a row though
I've gotten you stuff yeah yes but he
doesn't have to I believe people cookies
I make people cookies and cupcakes and I
give them type 2 diabetes as an act of
love that's what black people oh yeah
your cookies were amazing and they were
they were covered cookies here and like
I bring up cookies at Christmas for like
the office and I'll like do that so I
bake here's the great here's the great
irony of this movie though is because I
am an uncle and so there's very there's
very little pressure on me to give like
the gift of the Season you know that's
the parents job and then if I can swoop
through some cool Wiggles great if I had
kids and they really wanted one thing
I'm pretty sure I would very quickly
turn in to a Howard or a Myron because
you just want to see those kids happy
yes yeah but you would you would you
wait to the last minute still or would
you plan I wouldn't try to plan I hope
I'd have somebody helping me with that
process what is Reese what is Rita
Wilson doing Rita Wilson is dying a a
quiet death She's take care of the kids
yeah she can't throw the kit she can't
have somebody else watch the kid who
because she's got to know more than
Arnold that this kid has been wanting a
turbo Man doll forever it's only Turbo
Man just happened on December 24th can
we just talk about poor Rita Wilson this
because this is the one thing I will say
is Rita Wilson is a person and Tom
hanks's people I don't know I'm very
confused about that because they seem to
raise two very normal children and one
not so normal child and I'm just like
something happened there right but there
is something about the quiet desperation
in her voice trying to get this dude to
buy a toy and she goes like Howard and
I'm just like I I I'm more angry at her
character because her character was the
archetype for so many women thinking
like this is what you need to do to get
the 90s yeah of the 90s like there were
so many women like the Rita Wilson was
just Sarah Jessica Parker five years
earlier and now she's here trying to get
her you know version of big to be a
grown man that can walk and chew gum
think about his emotions and buy a
Christmas gift for your kid yeah like I
the Simplicity of how these men are
failing is just ugh it does I don't find
it comical anymore I will say I agree
with you with the ending where they
should have shown him showing up to the
karate class to the games to whatever
because that would have brought it full
circle him and Myron the kids could have
been on the same team I just think
there's a lesson here that is like the
conceited movie which is don't buy your
kids affection on Christmas if you're
there for them 364 days and you never
actually see either one of the
characters really learn that lesson
which I'm like I don't know what it is
about my brain it makes me glitch if he
was a true deadbeat dad he would have
gotten his kid in Nerf football the
official gift of the deadbeat dad and he
wouldn't have paid attention long enough
to see the disappointment in his kid's
face that it wasn't a turbo Man doll
because at least he probably only heard
turbo and Nerf had a really cool
football called a turbo for a long time
it would have been off brand though the
deadbeat dead yeah yeah it wouldn't have
been official Nerf it would have been
something that was like Nerf ass glad
that my father wanted to buy my
affection and I'm grateful for it
because that PS2 was dope wait so your
dad got you a PS2 so best Christmas gift
you ever got and then we'll close up
shop
a PS2 probably PS2 it's a very
competitive gift the first year it came
out um it was my stepdad buying my
affection but my dad had bought my
affection not long before that with like
I was an only child I should also add
and so like I had Nintendo I had Sega
the very first ones every time they came
out uh the only one I didn't have was
N64 because N64 was like a console that
you should play with other people like
that was amazing and I just it even at
that time I knew I was like I'm not
getting siblings and this is just
depressing so give me the single player
things like Sega and Nintendo and then
Microsoft when they came out with
PlayStation it was like they knew this
is just for you yeah yeah yeah whatever
um I think it was the N64 because I had
friends and family no offense to you uh
it's okay I knew I had a depressing
childhood there's a reason why this
movie hits different for me
this is the reason why this movie hits
listen yes if anyone listen to this be
like Jacqueline it needs I'm already in
therapy do not worry but this movie hit
me in a place that is not good it is too
close to home and it hurt yeah but
playing N64 with my friends GoldenEye
Mario 64 Mario Kart 64. and Pokemon Snap
Pokemon Stadium all that stuff I was all
about that so the only time that I ever
got competitive with any game that I
really want really any toy that I wanted
the in a turbo man way was I remember
Tecmo Bowl was like a sensation when it
came out for Nintendo right and then
tecmo's Super Bowl was coming out and it
was for Super Nintendo they made one for
Nintendo that I had Acquired and it was
great but then there was one coming out
for Super Nintendo and I remember Tecmo
I think they had like an ad in uh
Nintendo power or something and it said
hey just so you know when Tecmo Super
Bowl hit shelves it was there for like I
don't know 10 minutes and it's and every
game sold out so I don't know how I got
one of those games when I got one of
those games but I remember showing it to
my mom being like Mom we really got to
be on top of this thing so I used to
this day don't remember if we like went
to Electronics Boutique
like early and lined up I just remember
having a Tecmo Super Bowl for Super
Nintendo and I maintained it's still the
greatest football game ever made wow
sorry sorry Madden fans Tecmo Super Bowl
was the peak for me uh final word on
jingle all the way goes to our special
guest today and our producer Brian Perez
stumped for your movie thank you I will
say the Rotten Tomato score is way too
low for 19 it should be totally fresh
why is the audience score 38 who's who's
voting in the audience score I don't
know it's not my generation what you
were the audience score that's you
bringing it down Jacqueline we were 80s
latchkey kids this is different I was a
90s latchkey kid and this hits perfect
all the lone children voting that's
that's who's doing it yeah no it's
totally uh fresh and I love this movie
The Comedy again is so funny and the
action sequences are amazing so pretty
good family uh movie director resume for
Brian Lavon he's got Beethoven He's Got
The Flintstones those are both
pre-jingle all the way and then he's got
Are We There Yet in 2005 so guys
covering all the bases now Jingle All
The Way 19 and a good way to let us know
how you feel about that is our mail bag
you can hit us anytime Rotten Tomatoes
RT is wrong at rottentomatoes.com is the
email address there we go RT is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com is where you can send
us your thoughts on jingle all the way
or an upcoming movie that you really
think that we should be talking about in
this show like ketchup crew member
Antonio Washington who says Hey guys
love the podcast my movie suggestion is
a Christmas story I feel like the critic
scoring audience score is way too high
for this and he quoted classic film 90
certified fresh 88 audience score I've
watched it recently and it was boring
compared to a popular movie Like Home
Alone thanks Antonio shots fired at a
Christmas classic A Christmas Story
thoughts it's not a good movie okay it
is not a good movie okay little boy
consumeristic this white boy in his
dream moving but
there is a certain level of cutesiness
to that because even though it is
commercialistic it is a child
commercialistic Endeavor and let's be
real at age seven there is nothing more
important than a Red Rider BB gun I like
that one better it feels more Earnest
and I actually feel for the family more
yes in a Christmas story but I was never
a big Christmas we weren't A Christmas
Story family growing up so I never even
saw it until like five years ago really
yeah what's the big deal with the TBS
why are you playing it 24 hours a day
and have you said you sat down and taken
it in yes and yeah I would agree it's
not the best movie it's kind of boring
at times but there are some good moments
that like make it a classic so let me
give you all the racial divides so for
black people yeah it's not a Christmas
story it's not a Christmas story
it is either this Christmas yep uh soul
food uh the preacher's wife occasionally
The Color Purple because that's just
what happens when black women get
together
um and believe it or not Imitation of
Life which is like the tragic mulatto
story really yes it's wow Turner uh
Juanita
um she's her maid and yeah it's the
tragic mulatto story I think those five
hey ketchup crew if any black women or
black people are disagreeing with me
actually I would like to know this y'all
tell me what are your like specific
family ethnic sort of like Christmas
movies because I feel like I like the
best man's holiday there is another one
best man's holiday thank you there's
another one that is a great like black
folks Christmas movie and I feel like
guys playing for the New York Giants yep
he's about that the football scenes
aren't the best but he but he's about to
break the all-time rushing record but
he's also got this stuff at home but
they still have time for a 90s uh cover
performance in the living room pretty
pretty good yeah I would love to hear
what people say about that you do you
have a specific family Christmas movie
that's not I think we just put on Selena
like every time we didn't see them but
y'all would if y'all are families
together you find a reason to put on
Selena yes that's what I'm saying like
so what what is what is the white person
version of this I really want to know
outside of like classic Christmas movies
well it's the movie that's always
debated this time of year what Die Hard
oh that's the one Okay so we've set up a
trend so y'all let us know you're off
brand Christmas because like Scrooged is
the closest you would get but it's still
so on the nose Christmas Christmas Carol
especially if it's like this is what me
and my weird family watching right
because I guarantee you there's some
Nightmare Before Christmas Christmas
people Christmas Vacation Christmas
Vacation No No I gave you ours and
actually best man holiday is a little
late for me like I feel like younger
like yeah it was like 2015 or something
a little bit late for me so like they
had to be a part of the culture already
for me to be talking about it but like
yeah no I do think that there are
certain movies but to your point yeah by
the way filmed my hometown well the town
I grew up in yeah RT is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com email us with your
off brand with your specific Christmas
movies that don't necessarily have to
relate to Christmas we'd love to hear it
uh Brian thanks for joining us on the
show on this side yeah of the camera you
do a wonderful job engineering the whole
shebang so thank you for letting your
talents in front of the microphone as
well where can all the kids find you
when you're not telling me what to do
I'm not uh bossing you guys around
um you can find me on the Wenger show on
Amateur hour films we do sketches we do
podcasts we do it all on the amateur
films YouTube amateur films YouTube
check it out a lot of great shorts uh
we're just coming out of the spooky
season but they always make a good short
around that time of year as well so uh
for Jacqueline Coley
um do we get a streaming recommendation
I guess
um I I loved White Lotus before as a
thing so I love promoting White Lotus
yeah I haven't seen the new season I'm
excited saw it debuted yeah I don't
think I don't think I finished it last I
was like I get it and I'm just so good
did you get to the did you get to the um
do it I'll do it did you get to the
scene though I no and so that's what it
feels like I I jumped right before yeah
you really got to get to that team okay
all right Murray uh who he did win an
Emmy right F Murray or which one am I
white no um Murray uh Armand yeah yeah
if you wanted Emmy and he's got a new
show I will give a plug to a friend
Emily B Gordon and kamil's news welcome
to Chippendales is going to be on Hulu
and I think he's gonna get another
because he's playing the guy like the
the Rival of the the main Kumail
character oh nice so good spoiler alert
if you know that story crazy story crazy
story yeah I don't want to give it away
for these I know nothing yeah no watch
just watch the story because if you
don't know the story going blind because
I listen to the podcast did you listen
to the podcast yeah the podcast about
welcome to Chippendales which is what
the show is called by the way welcome to
Chippendales Camille nanjiani I think
October 24th all right yeah covered all
the bases here oh and Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong for Brian Perez check out Amateur
hour films on YouTube my esteem co-host
Jacqueline Coley I am commanders fan
Mark Ellis thanks for tuning in and
we'll see you next time right here at
Rotten Tomatoes from
[Music]